get LED through this pet shop right I
mean really it just looked like I had a
couple of after animals in it you know
what I mean it was a really sorry sight
LED upstairs at the back go in there
shaven-headed monster sitting behind a
table with his nine mil
right and that's the opening Gambit
that's how we're going to start the
conversation him with his nine mil
pointing at me
how did you get into undercover work
Peter well officially
I started when I was at Scotland Yard
when I went on to the central Drug Squad
back in 1985 when I was young fit and
fearless and walked through the swing
doors at the yard with my shoulders back
and my chest puffed out and was proud as
punch unofficially a few months earlier
when I was based at a CID office in
Kensington we had some information come
in about a guy who was selling LSD and
the only way to really discover if he
was or not was to go into an undercover
role and the guy was gay a very
flamboyant gay man so I went to Marks
and Spencer's bought myself a string
vest slicked my airbag and tried to look
like a 1980s gay fella rocked up at his
flat I knew the the buzzword or the code
word that I'd been given by the
informant for for the drugs got into his
flat had a quick chat with him and he
produced sheets upon sheets of LSD tabs
at which point I nearly gave him Art
Attack because I told him he was nicked
but that was all completely unofficial
and something that a bunch of us
Renegade young detectives had done of
her own back but about 86.87 I think it
was
when the yard realized we were being so
successful in terms of seizures and
arrests that they had to centralize it
all and so10 was set up and then of
course the Recruitment and all of that
became a bit more formalized after that
yeah I suppose I just sort of fell into
it really because I was a young cop uh I
wasn't a very good young cop if I'm
honest I was a bit crap at the uniform
stuff right
um why why uh I think I was too young
when I started I was 19 when I started
and I didn't realize how young I was how
younger 19 year older was because I
wasn't so good at the confrontation you
know I thought I could reason with
anybody even when they were still
punching me so I had a lot to learn
quickly put it that way but yeah I've
only got four years in when I got an
attachment to The Drug Squad and then
just one of them looked at me and said
you fancy having to go up buying some
crack right which wasn't the question I
was particularly expecting and the first
time I did it you know I was sent to
this knock on this door uh but come on
how did you prep for it what did you
wear and this is the thing again you
know when I said I had a lot to going
quickly yeah I didn't learn it that
quick because because it was sent they
sent me to this door yeah knocked in the
store and this huge guy answered the
door and says who are you you're not a
student are you I'm I hate students and
at that moment I thought
actually I don't know who I am I've got
no idea but that'll do yeah I'm a
student he says are you stupid I've just
told you I'd hate students but and then
he laughed because it was fine you know
you got a little handful of little wraps
and I got one of the wraps and I went
back to The Drug Squad like this there
you go I got it so what did you buy a
rock a coat of a rock of crack yeah just
a stone yeah just just a little rock
that was all and it's that easy really
what did they say when you handed it
over well as I was walking away from the
dealer he said
um
you take care now don't get yourself
arrested right which you thought was
quite considerate really yeah uh and has
brought it back and yeah they were very
happy you're at the the street level or
starting at the street level with the
purchase of the 10 pound bag the 20
pound bag we were going in at a higher
level yes into the sort of wholesale and
import part of the drugs industry and we
were getting introduced yeah yeah and
time and time again either by an
informant yeah or if an informant had
introduced an undercover cop and it was
a long operation in the undercover cop
might introduce another undercover
copper yeah it was always an era Menace
with all these people that I dealt with
certainly you know they'd be very jovial
sometimes and they'd have plenty of cash
to Splash around and we'll have another
bottle of that or we'll ever have a
bottle of that you know right well there
we've got a big difference between the
kind of work because very few of the
people that I dealt with were jovial and
yeah there'd be casual violence towards
me and there'll be no one buying me
drinks and things so different level
entirely I think but but the level that
you were at there and those villains
you've just just described yeah what
size parcel or Consignment would you be
looking to buy in that situation well
most of the time very small amounts I
was doing you know eighths of heroin
would be my my bigger ones I mean I did
some larger jobs where it went up to a
kilo for for one job but but if I'm
honest I I was an adjunct provocateur
for them anyway right they weren't
normally capable of that amount and it
came back at one percent pure right so
you can see what they did there but you
know occasionally we got bigger bigger
amounts but whereas I was buying kilos
yeah multi-kilos yeah the police would
say and the Press would say had a street
value of many millions of pounds yeah so
of course A lot of it was in flats and
luxury cars and maybe a hotel bar yeah
and all of that you know I was going to
buy Parcels with 50 Grand underground
330 Grand on one occasion you know so of
course it was it wasn't I would say
there was a constant air of Menace but
it was often well disguised with Joe
reality and keeping everything business
like
where did you stand on the taking gear
it didn't well I mean if I'd had to take
heroin it would terrify me yeah
um and I had a few risky moments where
that was close I remember I want one guy
in Brighton
said I don't trust you you're having my
blowback
um so he did his he did his foil and
it's and basically saying that I was
going to inhale his his smoke yeah so I
just yeah great yeah no problem just
pretended to and didn't inhale you know
like like Clinton claimed you didn't
hail I just thinking I hope you can't
see the smoke coming out the side of my
mouth yeah but I just said right that
was heroin so I just went as chill as
possible and relaxed and and fell for it
so I never had to take heroin none of
the other drugs would have particularly
worried me I don't think crack would
have done I never had to take any of
that but I made a massive mistake though
a massive mistake an operation I was
doing in a pub it was a long-term job
the main target was a antique burglar
major car thief uh big cocaine dealer
and for that job to give myself
something to talk about as much as
anything else I made myself out to be a
connoisseur of amphetamines
and I'm clearly not but you know I would
talk about benzos and and math and the
difference between hydrochloride and
sulfate and all this kind of
so anyway one day came up to me and said
hey you I've got something for you I
nailed up this little bag of this pink
toxic looking goo wow you could almost
see it dissolving the plastic in the
back
and I had a moment of reticence go
across my face I must have done because
he looked at me and I saw the moment
suspicion go across his face you know
those fleeting bits so I thought I've
got to pour fire on that pour water on
that fire of Suspicion straight away so
I thought I'm gonna have to have some so
I'll put some in my finger and put it in
my mouth and he said
you'll need more than that with your
tolerance
so I put some more in
and I felt that warm glow in my stomach
and and my heart rate's starting to go
and I was a mess you know I got out of
there I got to the safe location told
them what happened
I had to be driven home and I mean I
knew enough about the drug to know I
haven't overdosed or anything but it was
way more than a comfortable dose this
was anxiety extreme this was absolutely
horrible feeling
I remember being driven down thinking
I've got eight cans of lug in the fridge
at home that'll take the edge off yeah
and as I finish the eighth can yeah I'm
thinking I don't feel any different at
all any different I didn't sleep for
almost three nights it was that strong
but my house has never been so tidy it
was 40 pure base I've had quite a lot
and in my era there was
a lot of the the gangsters convinced
themselves that if the man on the other
side of the table doesn't take drugs
yeah then he's an undercover cop you
know and that was kind of with some of
them that would be their their
standpoint
now I didn't like getting stoned or you
know hoving up Charlie when I'm trying
to discuss business with people but so
often we'd agree the business in Broad
terms and then rocked back and there'd
be a drink involved if we were in
somebody's flat and all that kind of
stuff and of course the gear would come
out be it predominantly cannabis and
cocaine well I practiced and practiced
and practiced but putting together a
three skin a five skin a seven Skin So a
joint made out of three five or seven
seven sketches
really like you know it was like a
proper proper right I could I could
really put together a proper join and I
prided myself on it and I practiced with
octo Cubes at home at the weekend you
know it's kind of like our committed to
the cause I was
to anybody I'd take it whatever it was
from them as they put it on the table
and the skins or I'd produce some of my
own just again as a little deflection
kind of tactic put the joint together
and of course because I'm building it in
my hands there they don't actually
really see where I'm putting the gear so
what I would do is I would back load the
joint so in other words the front of the
joint which I would twist at the end and
that would be the bit that I'd spark up
that bit there right essentially I ain't
putting a gear there and I'd backload
the joints so I'd say well I built it so
I'm going to spark it right which was a
bit counter to the culture of then
handing the joint to someone but I'd
selfish you go well I've built it so I'm
going to spark it put the joint in smoke
it and a couple of big tokes but
essentially all I'm doing is smoking the
tobacco because I've front loaded it
yeah yeah you know couldn't always
happen sometimes I would build the joint
themselves and it passed around and it
you know you would but only if it was
going to be a deal breaker and with
cocaine again I practiced for hours I
became very Adept with a card at
chopping up lines and then I could
create initials right with it with the
joints and again people go oh I've never
seen that done before and you just go
well and again that would deflect from
me having a Hoover up at 20 pound note
and Hoover up a line yeah because I
think oldest guy really knows his stuff
that's that's that's cool I I used to
hate being stoned yeah if it undercover
it was horrible absolutely horrible
feeling that was really oh God although
once once I went to this um
it was a free party so it was about it's
the Rave scene free party and I got in
there and
I was with with a colleague woman again
and um someone says oh do you need
anything do you want some pills it gave
us two pills is how much she said oh no
you can have them and it was a proper
hippie free party there was no big
Etters in there they were just kids and
hippies
and so my companion she says no way I'm
putting evidence in against these just
no I'm not doing it right I'm not doing
it right
I thought actually no I don't want to
either because these aren't these are
not gangsters these are not criminals
they're just there for a dance so yeah
so I said so what do we do then
she said let's get stoned
and I thought
all right so we scored some grass and
some resin and we made a well she rolled
actually and then it double layers yeah
and we got stoned for the next three
hours dancing to some really great
techno right because I'm a fan of the
music right so yeah debrief where the
bosses go what what happened there well
the thing is as I'm walking out I'm
thinking my undercover time's over
because I'm like really still and we
both sat there trying not to put
ourselves laughing trying to answer
questions like what do people look like
well they were sort of average high
did you
ever have those moments when you thought
am I going to meet my Maker Now is this
going to be it
I've had quite a few to be honest
um God I mean
I suppose my most dramatic one uh was
I'd bought off this fairly decent sort
of regional
uh Giza right at the start of the job
and this is six months later but we've
got no footage of him got no
corroboration at all
so we were trying to wind the job up
well we needed this corroboration so but
he wasn't coming out being Hands-On he
was just sending Runners so
I knew he liked his clothes so I've got
some counterfeit Stone Island jackets
and I tempted him out to look at them
but he brought two of his mates with him
and I've not met them before
these are an example I've got loads more
if you want them and where did you
Source them from
um Customs right so so I'm in this car
park and he says yeah do you just want
to sell me these or are you after
something I'm thinking well I've not
bought any crack from you yet so if
you've got any white I'll have a 20
stone off you all right so we got this
back in the car and he's cutting off
this massive block a huge block of crack
right with a little razor blade and his
mates then start saying hang on how long
have you known him
how long and he's getting really
suspicious he pushed me up against this
railing right and starts feeling down my
jacket and he finds the camera so I'm
thinking in this moment you know the
adrenaline time slowing down thing
I'm thinking well if he convinces his
mate who I know
of what he's found I'm in trouble here
so what I've got to do is to block that
communication
so I just launched into this turret of
abuse and says what are you doing
picking at my jacket it's not even my
jacket I borrowed it this morning what
the are you doing picking up my
jacket
and I just launched at him and of course
he's a bit shocked like wow I wasn't
expecting that and then he starts to
doubt himself a little bit and then I
took the jacket off his other mate and
started folding it slowly as I can
move it in the into the and then I start
walking really slowly
and over my shoulder still just
maintaining this abuse so I've got to
stop him talking get halfway across the
car park hear this running feet behind
me I'm thinking maybe if I swing around
get one punch in you know
turn around it's the guy I know he says
I don't mind my mate he's a
and I said yeah he is he's been picking
up my jacket anyway don't you want this
this thing I don't think you want to
still want to sell me Crack are you
kidding me so I did the exchange all
nicely framed in the camera
and then I carried on walking but then
of course these mate managed to convince
him of what I found because I heard the
speech into the wheels the car zooms
across the car park I'm thinking no I
need to run now so I got running got to
the pavement and I turned left to the
side of the Ring Road and the car
followed me up the pavement and it's
roaring trying to get me right
and I sprinted and I got to where the
road sort of split uh whether the
roundabout and there's the battle
railings I just got to the metal
railings there was no room for the car
so it came to a halt I looked behind it
must have been less than two meters
behind me so they almost got me almost
and then it bumped on onto the road went
round the roundabout a couple of times
but from where I was at that point I
could walk quite easily to The
Pedestrian area I was separate from
quite quickly
anyway went back to Safe location did
the debrief told them hang on hang on
hang on hang on did you make your way to
a car and then go to the safe location
or uh no I put a call in for someone to
pick me up right all right
um yeah so it was like a like a
farmhouse they'd rented for the for the
operation
um gave them the number the description
the Intel Geezer went out went out came
back in and he was laughing yeah it says
I don't know why they didn't just shoot
you because there's loads of Intel
there's a gun in that car and you know
how really stupid things you find them
funny we're all herself laughing at that
like it was the funniest thing anyone
had ever said yeah but that was one of
the closest I think
they missed me by a bit about you
so I'm living in the witness protection
program at the time so I'm under all
that additional stress but the job still
wanted me to work Undercover
and my mental health is on the downslope
but I'm not really aware of that at the
time you know I feel like I'm really
stressed but I can still function
go to Moss side in Manchester into this
absolute
area of chronic social deprivation
get LED through a pet store what year is
this sorry
uh
1994.95 right okay
um get LED through this pet shop right I
mean really it just looked like I had a
couple of after animals in it you know
what I mean it was a really sorry sight
led up the stairs at the back go in
there shaven-headed monster sitting
behind a table with his nine mil right
and that's the opening Gambit that's how
we're going to start the conversation
him with his nine mil pointing at me you
know sitting on the table
so I didn't really want to dwell there
very long as you can imagine
and I agreed far too readily to a
purchase a sample purchase of an ounce
of cocaine and a kilo of cannabis
because we were going to do a you know a
bit of a jamboree bag of a deal right
you can tell I was not praying that the
peak of me powers now why on Earth would
I agree to that anyway leave there go
back to the bosses persuade them that
they should spend this three grand and
these people were top of the right at
the top of the list of targets at
greater Manchester police had on their
radar at the time so they were very keen
to bring them down so the three grand
expenditure is sanctioned and a few days
later together with one of the less
experienced you see guys I always wanted
to be my driver because they'd learn how
I did it kind of thing and we pull into
this service station I just go spotters
you know because you can identify I mean
you know they're there and they're
they're Aspire so they have guys from
the minute we we drive into the car park
and I think I'll meet him in a in a cafe
within them my way service station again
they make it clear that they're carrying
right
and
basically I think it's fair to say that
I am
lost my bottle
but I'm really glad that I did
so what I did was I I took possession of
the what I thought was the kilo of
cannabis and the ounce of gave him the
three grand and basically just got out
there as quickly as we possibly could as
we're driving down the motorway I went
to check the parcel newspaper or
something no it was it was done the
Cannabis the kilo of cannabis was
compressed animals of some description
and the kilo cocaine was just some sort
of white powdery nonsense most
definitely not cocaine so of course all
the emotions that I'm feeling there
right number one are massively
embarrassed because somebody who thought
he was like top undercover Tech you know
what I mean it's just been at over
completely for over three grand so I'm
embarrassed I know I'm gonna get one
hell of a freaking rollerkin when I get
back and I was disappointed for the for
the youngster who's driving with me
because he thinks it's gonna reflect
badly on him as well but I'm saying to
him no no no no no no no no no I will
not have a bad word said about you you
know this was this is my error but
actually you know and I thought that
fairly soon and I think to this day I'm
so glad I didn't check that parcel there
and then yeah because it would have just
been a straight robbery yeah exactly
they'd shot me and taken the three grand
that's what they were Always setting it
up for there was no win in that scenario
none at all so I'm actually quite glad
now I now unequivocally without doubt
look back on all of that the sacrifices
the stress
and it was nothing other than a complete
and utter
waste of time are there less drugs on
the street no did we actually do
anything really constructive and for the
benefit of society well some of the
newspapers their headlines screams that
you know this is a great part of the
battle of the War on Drugs but it was
all nonsense just a complete waste of
time yeah I couldn't agree more at least
95 percent of undercover work and the
use of informants is about drugs so
we're talking a drug war tactic mostly
and yeah everything I did it's not just
that it was a waste of time
it's not just that we haven't prevented
drugs getting to the streets it cause
harm to loads of individuals vulnerable
people you know the level I was working
that's that was part of my job as part
of my ruthlessness but also made society
more dangerous because
our kind of work
it sharpens the sword of organized crime
it makes them adapt and more efficient
more brutal more ruthless because
they've got to out thinkers and they've
got to navigate what we do that's a
brilliant point
so we've actively made them better them
better and Society more dangerous we've
also increased the corruption because
you know you catch a gang it takes over
it's the rival gang in it yeah so a gang
increases their power don't they yeah if
they increase their share in the market
they've got more disposable income if
they've got more disposable income they
will always and they do always invest in
corruption so the mechanism of the kind
of policing that we've done has actively
increased corruption
we're part of a growing worldwide
movement yeah aren't we we're part of a
growing worldwide movement of police and
other law enforcement
who want an evidence-based drug policy
you want an end to this ridiculous War
on Drugs you know with what how the
police deal with drugs now do you think
there could be things done differently
that would influence politics or is it
up to the cops to do
well I don't think
um the responsibility to change our drug
laws and to move away from the nonsense
prohibition world that we live in at the
moment is entirely the responsibility of
the police their responsibility is to
enforce the law yeah and not change it
but you and I both know that there are a
growing number of voices within policing
that think it is a nonsense and in many
regards policing has already decided
that possession of cannabis is going to
be decriminalized because I increasingly
hear stories of small amounts being
seized and dropped down a drain for
example rather than somebody being
issued with some Community punishment or
a public spaces protection order but
legalization and regulation is the only
answer there is no other answer no
absolutely absolutely regulation is the
way to take control away from Criminal
organizations it is down to the
politicians and we have to keep
influencing them but I think it's also
important to know how policing can
influence public opinion because you
know the police are showing this public
seizures all the time they're showing
seizures of you know the Big Blocks of
cocaine pain or cannabis grows and if
it's not in the media it's on social
media and the trouble is the public see
that and they think oh well the current
system must be working because look at
that big pile of drugs look at that gang
the police have arrested the fact is
that none of those seizures have caused
anyone to go without their drug of
choice
none of those seizures
have reduced crime and none of those
seizures has made society safer
now when police institutions start being
honest
about the impact of those arrests in
those seizures well we'll get changed
quicker so so there is a responsibility
on policing yeah but that's turkey's
voting for Christmas isn't it because
the police are not going to say seizing
drugs is a complete waste of time
because that's how they Justified their
existence I mean I went to a meeting of
our local safer neighborhood policing
team and top of their arrests were drug
dealers three people arrested all that
kind of stuff they they don't show the
void they've created being filled by
other criminals and therefore an
increase in crime they're quite
potentially in increasing violence that
doesn't get recorded anywhere no it
doesn't and yet we see it played out we
see it played out with the increase with
the knife crime epidemic you know young
people using knives most of that is
connected to the illicit drug Market
most of it quite quite quite basically
that is that is the truth
it's not reported in that way they talk
about knife crime in this sort of
isolated concept this is about the drug
markets it's about Prohibition
the murders I mean we we've been of all
days yeah today of all days the finest
example
tragic example of the Folly of allowing
criminals to run the fourth biggest
industry in the
world's market yeah bigger than textiles
and we've all got we're all wearing
textiles every single person watching
listening yeah and we've all got a
wardrobe and the industry is bigger than
that today tragically Thomas Tommy
Cashman will be sentenced for murdering
Olivia Pratt Corbell that beautiful
nine-year-old girl who died in Liverpool
in August of last year
he a self-confessed drug dealer
set out that night to shoot another drug
dealer word on the street tells me the
dispute was all over drugs
and as a result of that Olivia dies that
is her death is a direct result
primarily of Thomas cashman's actions of
course but also the fact that we leave
violent criminals who possess guns to
run this Global industry it's so
nonsensical
the if it hadn't been thought of it
wouldn't be thought of now would it you
wouldn't go you wouldn't go let's get
all the most dangerous people on the
planet and give them a massively
lucrative industry yeah it's so absurd
isn't it yeah it's just beyond beyond
stupid
well I remember one one occasion we
dropped off uh
five million in the boot of a car to
some Colombians who on a Friday
and they came back and uh on the Monday
morning you know they dropped us some
other stuff off in another car we come
back Monday morning and I said where the
money was
and they've been driving about Amsterdam
all day well all weekend with five
billion pound in cash in the boot didn't
even know it was there